all right we hit record before I have
too much time to overanalyze this and
not do it and live in a constant state
of paralysis initiated by insecurity
maybe that's my new intro No hi my name
is Greg stop baby no no you know your
life is different now welcome to another
edition of i watch way too much reality
television and I need someone to talk to
about it the working title of this
series this week I started talking to
you about all the reality TV shows I
watched and it was very fun for me it
was not fun for some of you and you know
what I don't care I don't so we're gonna
keep going with it and I hope that maybe
you eventually find something that you
enjoy about this because I really like
this I guess to feel happiness you
should pursue the things that you enjoy
doing that provide you some sense of
fulfillment I read it on a bumper
sticker
so let's talk about reality television I
took notes what a dork last week I
talked about bachelor in paradise and
are you the one this week I'm gonna talk
about those two and then we're gonna
talk about some other shows that I'm
watching because I watched all of them
all of them oh I watch all of them I
don't want to try and go a little
quicker than we did last week but you
get it let's talk about southern charm
it's a reality TV show about a bunch of
charming southerners it's on Bravo they
live in Charleston do they live in
Charleston they live somewhere where
there's like fox hunting and an ironic
duck hunting without a Nintendo Hey
grits they own silverware that's
actually silver they got traditional
morals and modern mistakes oh did I just
write a tagline god I'm depressingly
great at this my quick thoughts on this
season so far Shep is a petty little
batch this season
Oh I don't know what kind of drinking
game they play in the south but uh he
ended up with a stick up his ass Jeb's
always fun he's got Peter Pan syndrome
he's never wants to grow up he never
wants to settle down and it seems like
it's making him less happy-go-lucky and
more bitter go off on everyone
yeah real testy with everyone now it's
just like annoying to watch oh but he
did get a little french bulldog and that
helps his image that's a likeable
accessory but he did name it after
his friend that he picks on all the time
named Craig he cannot not be petty
Craig is an interesting character cuz
he's clearly spiraling from break up
with his girlfriend of a few years that
is now in a really great new
relationship Craig to me is like if a
grandmother decided that she wanted to
rush a fraternity he drinks a lot me
makes pillows which I can see as my
future you found a passion for making
pillows and now he's trying to make that
a business which is hard to watch the
pillows look like pillows but it'd be
like if I based on my cooking videos was
like I'm gonna go become a Michelin chef
I'm not gonna go to school for it I'm
not gonna do any training my skill sets
are pretty perfect right now I'd be very
hard to watch Oh Candace just like the
the mom of the group in a way and now is
an actual mom she just had a kid she
just openly talks about how much
motherhood sucks and I'm really here for
it I think it's real fun to watch
Candace be candid about the joys of
motherhood being miserable I love it
ashley is back and Ashley's like this
[ __ ] malfunctioning fashion Furby I
don't like it it's like when you watch a
chihuahua in any temperature that's not
a hundred degrees and you're just like
it's gonna break that's what I feel
every time Ashley comes on the scene
okay those are my quick thoughts about
southern charm next Oh 90 day fiancé
this is a TLC franchise if you guys
haven't heard highly recommend basically
90-day fiance for those that don't know
is based on the k1 visa so people in the
United States if they find love overseas
they can apply for this k1 visa which
means that their significant other comes
to the United States and then they have
90 days to get married and then they get
the green card or something
I don't but they've expanded this
franchise because it's done so well too
before the 90 days and after the 90 days
and it's just a carousel of cluster 3
constantly I can't even keep up with it
and that's coming from me who makes time
to keep up with all of it I hardly call
my parents but I know the parenting
skills of everyone on these reality
television programs I'm fine with it if
I don't think about it 90 days fiance
should also be called 90 day divorcee
the log line for 90-day fiance is
basically everyone is they also recently
started doing
fiancee the other way which means
Americans go to the respective countries
of their significant others for 90 days
or something I don't know the full
logistics of that one but it's crazy
everyone's having a bad time
no one is thriving laura's this like
middle-aged American woman and she's got
a lover and guitar that she went to see
and she brought like a vibrator with her
to spice up their bedroom because
apparently he's not good at pleasuring
her and she's made it clear on
television he got very upset and I got
to watch it happen
Oh Carini and Paul have been on
basically every version of the 90 day
fiancé franchise and now they're on 90
day fiancé the other way Paul is trying
to live in Carini small village town and
Karina is pregnant with their child
which Paul doesn't fully believe he
thinks that she's cheating on her but
Paul is a certified lunatic he has arson
on his record because his ex girlfriend
cheated on him and now he applied for
citizenship in this new country and
they've denied it because they've called
him a terrorist he is not happy and you
know what he did he ran into the
backyard and locked himself in a chicken
coop you'll need a job cuz baby
I just cannot deal with it anymore
Paul has the emotional tools to maintain
an adult relationship in a foreign
country with a baby on the way
yikes it's a goddamn mess and I can't
stop looking at it
there's so much to say about 90 day
fiancé I'm not gonna get too much more
into it let me know what you guys think
about this season if you're watching
Real Housewives of Orange County started
the original Real Housewives franchise
don't know how to feel about this season
to start off a little tame but I
promises to get spicy who have I become
Vicki who is the original og housewife
of all the housewives is not a housewife
this season she's been demoted to
friends so she's not in the opening
credits Wow Vicki is tough to watch for
me you know those stress balls that have
the eyes on them and when you squeeze in
the eyes pop out she does that a lot
she's also super religious and believes
in Jesus which makes sense because Jesus
also ran around telling people a lot of
lies and then just sort of ran away from
all the conflict and hasn't come back
don't forgive her for accusing a mother
of having a coke problem and causing
irreparable damages family name and /
young daughter oh then there's a girl
named Bronwyn who's on this season she's
got like a ton of kids and her mom has
like rainbow colored dreadlock so a wild
season indeed Vicki and Kellie are at
odds which makes sense that both like
manic people that will stab you in the
back with words and then when you're
like ow like there's an actual knife in
my back they're like you walked into me
I was holding it yes and I like had it
at the right angle to stab you but you
you walked into it you walked into it
I everyone holds knives in front of them
like that all the time so that's real
fun Oh married at first sight super into
married at first sight
married at first sight is exactly what
it sounds like three professionals a
pastor a sociologist and a sexologist
pair up people and then they meet each
other at their wedding day when they
walk down the aisle and they get married
at first say it's a social experiment
for six weeks where they live together
and they see if the marriage works out
or if they want a divorce at the end of
the six weeks and this season does not
look promising I feel like I'm watching
a bunch of like kids at band camp play
house together
I have very
no hopes that any of them are going to
make it one girl's a virgin and she's
married to what seems like the nicest
guy that I've ever seen on a reality
television program and it's finally
admitting that he's having a hard time
being married to a woman that's a virgin
cuz that's a lot of pressure and that's
a very human feeling I feel for him
another couple is like a very
emotionally unavailable basketball
player and like a very tiny
schoolteacher its spoiler alert not
going well he like doesn't stay at the
apartment that they're supposed to stay
in and then she cries a lot and records
herself crying it's very internet but
he's like a basketball player that plays
like internationally I guess and it's
very fun to watch him try to talk to the
the therapists and such because he does
it like he's doing like a post game
interview or like you can't leave
someone that has abandonment issues he's
like I'm doing my best I'll try harder
next time that is something I have to
work on and yeah it didn't work out
today but you know I'm not gonna give up
it is so weird
also there's a couple where the girl
hasn't dated anyone in ten years and the
guys clearly into her but she's got
walls up and it's like watching two like
Disney characters like but one's kind of
horny and one is not and then there's a
couple that could make it or could
absolutely ruin each other's lives
they're kind of sloppy sloppy all over
the place one girl's like super
spiritual into crystals has like a very
intense close relationship with her dad
to the point that on her wedding day
her dad was like he's taking my daughter
and my love and I Oh Jess she's my loves
like a little like Electra complex eco
and then the other guy is just like
apparently a horndog that keeps giving
her like UTI is because he wants to all
the time it's all over the map I don't
know what's gonna happen but I'm gonna
keep watching also my favorite thing
about that show is the interlude music
that they play in between scenes it's
always just like royalty free like it's
gonna happen for you or like you saw I
was the one at night when we saw the Sun
it is the dumbest music ever please go
find it listen to it are you the one on
MTV somebody wanted me to explain this
show
hard to explain it's basically more
experts take all these people to live in
a house and they've paired them up where
they each have a perfect match that's
residing in the house with them and
through the course of the season they
all have to try and match up and find
their perfect one and if they all match
up with their perfect ones as allotted
by these experts they all split a
million dollars but now it's getting
down to the wire where they only have a
couple weeks left and they could go home
empty-handed if they don't figure this
out Danny did what Danny does best he
did some statistics some math and he
started to figure out just based on
probability where the perfect matches
are and turns out jasmine and Nora are a
perfect match which is bonkers because
the episode before noir was stabbing a
balloon instead of punching Jasmine in
the face and so apparently that's
flirting now that we know that they're a
perfect match that was foreplay also at
one point during an episode Danny quoted
a Beckett to CAI which might be the most
intelligent thing anyone's ever said on
MTV in the history of MTV but now that
the beam ceremony where they feel like
they finally have like a handle on like
where they all lie with each other every
time they have a beam ceremony where
they try and guess and see how many
perfect matches they have everyone
dresses like a different spice girl
every single person that could be a
spice girl except for Danny he dresses
like an IT guy but it's part of his
brand oh and then we're gonna find out
via this ceremony if Justin and Max are
an actual couple Max is freaking the
[ __ ] out if they aren't which is bonkers
to me because you just figure out your
perfect couple and then each other after
the show this isn't the binding we're
not talking married at first sight here
guys bachelor in paradise oh man you
guys got sent home cuz they started
punching each other over pinata
oddly it was like a very symbolic
reflection of like the state of the
world right now which makes me sad also
I realize that this entire season is
just one long commercial for stagecoach
and condoms if Jed isn't performing at
stagecoach next year they're really
missing out also does JPJ have like an
actual medical like gag reflex that we
should be like concerned about they keep
spitting up and coughing up a lot of
stuff oh you didn't Caitlin went to have
a conversation because Christina keeps
like wheezing her way into the Blake
situation
just friends one of the funniest girl
moves of all time is when they were
walking away to have their conversation
and Christina just looked up and down
and said oh I like your shorts to talk
about you
Caitlyn oh is that so I'm going to go
talk to her oh my gosh nuts by the way
thank you that's basically taking off a
white glove and slapping someone in the
face with it before a duel and then in
this conversation they were talking
about Blake and how she keeps kind of
like [ __ ] blocking him from exploring
relationships with other people and then
Christina got very defensive about if he
wants to give her a friendship rose he
could and then they kept saying
friendship rose over and over again I
felt like I was watching like two
Catholic schoolgirls talk about their
virginity it was uncomfortable and I
tuned out and then Demi has been having
this like moral dilemma because she was
dating a girl before this show started
and she talked to Chris Harrison about
it who is the master puppeteer of all of
this and then they brought Christian the
girl she was dating to the beach and she
chose her over Derick that she had been
spending all of her canoodling time with
and now Christian is staying at the
beach for the rest of the season with
Demi turns out this show is an Outback
Steakhouse there are no rules I think
that's great for Demi but also now
anything can happen I hope one of them
goes with the Chris Harrison is like you
know what I miss my dogs I had a really
great relationship with my dog before
this season started so we could get
goose here also I miss my phone and we
will get my phone here cuz I I heard
that there's no rules anymore I have a
broad just sequestered here until
stagecoach next spring and then will be
set free great
oh and Nicole wrote a song for clay that
I want to forget about a lot well there
you go there's all my random thoughts
about reality TV this week leave
comments down below and what your
thoughts have been what shows you want
me to watch or comment on that I haven't
already don't forget to subscribe to
this YouTube channel and make videos
other than that I don't know does the
pool get cleaned because it's there's a
lot of like
mmm